A definitive way of writing a resume or CV - "curriculum vitae" - doesn't exist,...
...but here are some tips that might help.
Resumes must be tailor-made for specific jobs, have a clear layout, and should be informative but concise.
Unless it is a technical or academic resume where four to five pages are acceptable,...
...you should try to fit your details on about two to three pages.
Don't print on both sides, use separate sheets and put your name in the footer.
Be positive and honest in your descriptions.
The highest qualification is mentioned first.
The upper middle part of the first page is the spot that people tend to focus on.
Try to place important information there.
Don't experiment with strange fonts.
Times New Roman and Arial in size twelve are standard for normal text.
Many resumes are nowadays read on screen.
Therefore, with slightly wider letters, Verdana may be a good choice at font size ten.